foreign
[Music]
have heard of like a couple people using
it for a certain things I do
I do not yes yeah unfortunately yes yes
I have I've seen people on Tech talk but
I haven't seen like like my friends
using it right now
[Music]
homework I want to say homework
assignments yeah for homework assignment
uh I'm sure I've seen it but not really
for exams no I don't think it's well I
mean actually it's probably possible but
I don't think so I mean most exams are
in person so I don't really see how how
you could use it in person yeah I mean I
think most people probably use it just
for homework assignments but I think
everyone well I think like most people
who use gbt like they also will use it
on part of their exams for essays and
stuff like that I see a lot of stuff
about it online all the time
um there are a bunch of issues with
plagiarism and um
AI that's enough for the assignment it's
just for like the assistants to complete
the alignment but not like copy paste
from the tragic routine
[Music]
no I haven't I haven't yet but I am but
I am curious out of curiosity yet
honestly no oh yeah I have no I don't
use it yeah of course so like if I was
falling behind on glasses I'd actually
use it as a 30 degree stores so I just
keep asking questions based on what was
on the slides and it kind of got me like
really prepared for like exams and like
homosexuals only a time I've ever really
seen it was an episode of South Park
I saw an episode of South Park and I was
like oh this kind of looks interesting
but I haven't really experimented with
it since
this is pretty
creative and also it's really effective
and efficient like when I type something
and it will give the answer like quickly
I thought it was really intelligent it
kind of scared me because I was like are
robots like taking over the world
um it kind of freaked me out but it was
cool how intelligent it really was
actually I just type the What is love
like this question yeah because I'm
curious about which rgbt will answer
because uh his AI model and he don't
know what the love specifically is but
please search on the internet and tell
me that love is somebody felt something
yeah it's
it's just the Google answer I was
talking to someone and they were kind of
asking you to trade to a leader and I
was kind of going up to become president
of an org and so they were like let's
search up like traits of a leader and it
gave me like lots of cool trades and
like all of like the explanations which
is very nice